[music playing]
NARRATOR: What would you
do, if you could not chew?
Did Dr. Seuss write this
script or maybe, Roald Dahl?
[singing] What would you
do if you could not chew.
Simple.
You just thrash your food apart.
Alligators go through 2,000
to 3,000 teeth in a lifetime.
Seems inefficient,
but hey, they haven't
evolved in millions of years so
if it ain't broke, why fix it?
Females also keep an
obsessive vigil over a mound
of decomposing brush and mud.
Why?
Within, lie three dozen
eggs, but she needs
to be in freshwater to survive.
She's dug a small wallow near
her nest to rest in the water,
while keeping an eye on it.
Helicopter parent-- typical.
Here, she can relax
and let her heartbeat
drop to two beats per minute.
I wish I could get
that kind of rest.
When her eggs begin to
hatch, she digs them up,
and inspects them, one by one.
Her monstrous jaws
spell doom for her prey,
but a comfy nursery
for her babies,
as she ferries
them to the river.
They're like the minivans
of the reptilian world.
She'll look after them for up
to a year or more, fiercely
defending them from
all threats, including
raccoons and other gators.
If I was a raccoon, I would
not mess with a baby alligator,
just seeing that footage
of it, killing that deer.
Are you kidding?
Go eat a frog or something.
Come on.
Your life is short.